hello and welcome to episode 162 of the
gamespot after dark podcast i am your
host tomorrow saying joined in the san
francisco studio by the one and only
maestro of live streaming tech sean luke
sabki hello how's it going it's going
well and we are joined remotely by newly
upgraded
jake decker
uh in two ways i got faster internet and
i got my steam deck today like 45
minutes ago incredible scenes and we are
joined also remotely
by the one and only philbin
ben jenker
hello how's it going uh i also got new
internet but it was like two weeks ago
so it's exciting i guess with some info
what the
for the for the internet oh it's it's
like 10 10 gigabit like nonsense
like business class it's stupid wow
things go slow fast holy moly and well
if there's anyone at gamespot that needs
it
it's probably ben
you basically
upload every video on
on the site so it makes a lot of sense
yeah
for sure
all right
it's been an interesting week in the
world of video games oh you can see that
again
there's been various events um on the
sadder side multiple
outlets have been going through layoffs
ranging from future to g4 to sadly
fanbite recently
so i guess at the top of the show if
you're watching this live or listening
to it later it's worth just reaching out
to people who you may know they're
working there and showing them some love
they could definitely use it right now
yeah um it's a wild old time it is an
easy covering video games it might from
the outside seem like oh it's all fun
and and a good time over there and it
can be
but we also at the whims of corporations
that frequently don't understand what we
do why we do it or how to
let us do it right
and they set unrealistic expectations
and then when we naturally can't meet
them
we suffer the consequences
so yeah it's it's tricky to be in the
world of games journalism and it becomes
even trickier by the day so like we said
show the people that do the work that
you like or enjoy some love whether
that's here
or any of the aforementioned
publications that
have been going through layoffs
um with that said we're going to do our
best to keep things moving
um keep things as light as we can and
discuss some of the news but before we
get into that
let's talk about some of the things that
we've been playing
experiencing and i'm going to start
with
ben
oh
i bet you know where i'm going to go
first it's uh everyone's favorite time
to update we're playing final fantasy
14. it's a thing that never stops um
but uh i guess most recently i can keep
it short i promise
uh they put out the the newest raid tier
and
uh we've actually we had to reform our
static group a bit
for for running it and we've actually
got uh everyone's favorite other ziv
uh sympathizer
uh michael hyam in our group oh so he's
running with us we're we're all working
together to get through the current raid
tier and it's a very good time
uh
so yeah that and they had the patch with
the most recent story that came out
island sanctuary so you can animal
crossing all the things and
it's uh it's real cool yeah you get a
motorcycle for planning things and
clearing out an island
i wish that's how it worked in real life
for real it'd be a real good time
jake are you are you still
trying to get uh caught up or have you
have you given up i
i i wouldn't say i've given up but i've
definitely put it on the back burner not
so much because i've lost interest but
more because of just
game after game i've been covering last
of uh you know last of us was all last
week i mean
i don't know it it's been busy but i am
itching to get back to it i still have a
ways to go to get to any of that stuff
though i think i'm i think i'm like
two-thirds through heaven's word i'm
like
level 57 and i think it maxes at 60. i'm
sure there's more to do after that but
um yeah sean
where are you at
oh i'm um
i think i'm like red at the end of uh
realm reborn um i didn't skip it like a
coward um i i chose to
struggle through it um but
yeah i uh admittedly have not had the
time or motivation to get through that
like
last little chunk i need to before i get
to the good stuff here's the thing ben
you're the perfect person to answer this
is there a vati video for final fantasy
xv 14.
i don't know if i could point it once
yeah or like a good video that you know
of that is like oh you can just get
every bit of story information you need
from bro reborn by watching this
you know
that most hour long video
that's all i'm allowing
yeah there are very good breakdowns for
specific uh expansions if you want to
just kind of go for that
uh you do lose a little bit of the the
like feel for it it is paced in a way
but you could definitely find a video
that would give you a good overview keep
in mind that i've played all the way up
to the end of the realm reborn twice
before having my characters right it's
true you might you've had
a very rough run of it uh yeah
specifically uh so i totally understand
there's definitely
a video especially since you've played
through it already you'll be like oh i
already know all this yeah yeah this
makes sense and it'll keep you going
yeah that's that's what i think i'm
going to have to resort to at this point
just go
and watch a recap and then jump back and
jump into like why is it heavens road
next
yeah heavensward and you get to learn
about the housing crisis and
uh people wanting to
do all sorts of things to dragons
heaven's word picks up a lot uh i i
thought for the story and it seems like
everyone kind of feels that way because
i i did do most of a realm reborn as
well like i was well over halfway
through it and then i slowed down
because they were gonna cut some
missions and quests when in that update
a couple years ago but i thought there
and i then i tried starting over again
and i had like done the first 30 hours
of that game twice so i was i was like i
i can't do it again but then i did find
some videos i watched to catch me up on
things that happened mo like catch up on
like the last 10 and then remind me of
what happened in a realm reborn and uh
not a lot happened in a realm reborn at
least for most of it
yeah it does a lot of kind of like
oh there are these people that cried too
hard no monster showed up and you went
and fought the monster it's pretty cool
anyway we're gonna do that three more
times yeah it does introduce some
important characters though and and and
sets up cool moments eventually and i
feel
like i'm gonna miss out on some of that
because i didn't get the full experience
but i'm not regretting skipping yet so
interesting
i think i think i'm going to jump in it
soon and use the older watch the video i
think i want to watch a video see if you
have one ben recommend it and then i'm
gonna i'm gonna then i'm gonna reinstall
do the skip and start playing heaven's
word
i think that's the way for me that's my
that's my path forward
just send me the name of um we can play
together yeah let's just say the name of
where i need to be a four-person group
right here we can run all the dungeons
and and i'm a tank and people don't like
playing as tanks so that's taken care of
there you go
although you're a tank too right ben i
i'm a tech but i also
have almost everything leveled up i can
heal like a dps i can
yes it's all good
uh what else have you been playing
uh a lot of fighting games as it turns
out because they fit in really well into
a
a busy work schedule slash mmo schedule
so i've been doing uh specifically a lot
of guilty gear strive with uh some of my
friends
uh which has been a really good time to
kind of get back into that it's a
fantastic fighting game with a great
soundtrack and excellent characters
and uh
uh the most recent uh edition uh
bridget's fantastic
um
very very big fan but i'm still
still playing my usual bike and soul bad
guy and faust
characters but
um
along with that doing a lot of street
fighter 5 because i'm excited for six
which i'm sure we'll talk about later on
too so i'm very excited for that
um and the other kind of surprise one
that's kind of like a cool relaxed deal
is uh playing a lot of the the jojo
fighting game remake oh yeah
uh and i think they did a fantastic job
with it it's still not got the best in
that code but
uh if you want to play a cool fighting
game that is pretty accessible and also
still has a bit of depth but also is
really ready to throw fan service at you
it's a very good time um i feel like as
the host of a jojo podcast i should play
this game although it will probably be
hella spoilery i uh well i i know jojo
pretty well oh okay so for you yeah yeah
so there's like i've never watched every
episode start to finish gotcha but i've
always got up to date with jojo okay
okay yeah as fun as it would be it would
sadly not make a
great quick look to have like lucy and
jeff play yeah because that as cool as
that would be they would be hella
spoilery i mean i'm like hesitant to
play it because i know like part seven
characters are in it and i'm like
haven't read that one yet don't i don't
want to get spoiled yeah
i i still i'm still like
i think i'm halfway through part five
i need to i need to pick that up and get
into the the new stuff that also just
kind of like kicked off but
uh you can also kind of like it splits
up the roster a bit so you can kind of
keep to the stuff you know if you want
but yeah
um
and it's very cool do you listen to jeff
just bizarre adventure
uh not as much as i'd like to listen to
the first couple ones fake fan wow oh
jeez i've been called out
[Laughter]
um but yeah i think i want to try that
heck yeah do it yeah cool uh if you if
you get it for pc i'd be down to to play
with you too okay i'll let you know i
think actually i might i might actually
have the special edition oh okay yeah so
i i just don't know what version i've
got so i need to unbox that and have a
look at it they were like they sent they
were like do you want this uh jojo's
speculation i was like i feel like if i
say no i'm coming korean suicide at this
point
um so yeah they sent me one which is
fine
um but yeah uh three five five year are
you enjoying it
yeah uh i i think that games come a
really long way uh
from when it first came out
uh
it's it's i really like i think my
favorite thing i'm realizing like beyond
character fixes and balances and
characters they've added is i really
like how kind of weird experiments he
they got with
uh character gameplay design
and also like the weird extra flourish
animations they had to do a lot of
character it's like you'll have uh what
is it g the the weird definitely not q
uh president of earth or whatever
and if you like
if you do a grab with him he'll do the
grab but then he'll also like stand up
and straighten his tie and like point at
the crowd really quick if you let the
animation play out and i think that's
real neat to kind of have
uh and then i'll also think about like
gameplay-wise you got like for instance
cody who is from a beat-em-up game and
they gave him like a beat-em-up style of
gameplay where you you get an auto combo
on pressing x over and over and you can
modify that with pressing different
buttons and
it's it's neat that they kind of went
and did that kind of stuff it's it's fun
but it is literally it's literally just
holding me over until i can finally play
six because six i i'm watching videos
over and over again
uh i i i i
want to try it so badly
i'm definitely going to give six a fair
shot as someone who
has dabbled in fighting games for
for a while apart from smash i
i feel like six seems like a good one to
good one to try to get into i think john
luke you would mention doing that too so
maybe we'll we'll start off yeah fight
club
camp yeah i would love to yeah i mean i
i remember when five came out and i said
i'll make five my my like the one that i
really try and make it like a because i
play fighting games but i've never made
an earnest effort in like specifically
the online and stuff and i was like five
will be the one and then five came out
and i was like
nah this ain't it um yeah i know that
game eventually got there but when it
launched i was like
five was busted online for really yeah
and it just i i couldn't really stick
with it and i was like i have not played
i reviewed it
i reviewed arcade edition first peter
brown did the original gave a seven i
reviewed arcade edition and i don't
think i've touched it since that day
that was when they added
sakura yeah they had like a bunch of new
characters i think that second uh v
trigger whatever it's called um yeah
everyone got a yeah i remember i
remember that and then i was like
okay that's enough for some reason
whenever i review
fighting games after i've finished
reviewing it i'm just done
like i very rarely will go back to it
there's something about the review
process for fighting game that kills
most interest in it for me like i
reviewed soul calibur the latest one
just never played that again literally
never touched it again and that's
interesting because that's like right
before the online really kicks in the
phone exactly but i think it's like the
stress of it all oh sure yeah and then
granblue fantasy was the same where i
reviewed it and i
i was like this is good it's fine and i
just never touched it again marvel vs
capcom infinite reviewed that didn't
touch it again it died
it killed itself
there is such a commitment with fighting
games right like
and and it's tough like
i got really good at smash bros during
my time off at gamespot because i didn't
have to play anything unless i wanted to
so i just mostly played smash bros and i
think i got a lot better although i
haven't played in well so i'm probably
not good anymore
but uh that's kind of my main concern
was trying to get into sf6 is that i
know
i'm sure out of the gate i'll be into it
and i'll hold strong but then you know
another game will release and i'll have
to drop right right probably won't come
back um but we'll see i mean
it looks really solid i'm super
interested in the um
how that single player is gonna pan out
because i don't know walking around the
city doing quests and street fights i
mean we could just get into what they
showed this morning at the capcom oh
yeah like i'm very much down if we want
to jump there's like a character creator
that looks crazy and they're like we
borrowed this from other video games
that we are making yeah i was like oh
cool yeah like just everything about
that has
way more effort than it should
but in like the best way possible yeah
it's like they they remember the
criticism of street fighter 5 where it
came out where it was like very bare
bones yeah and it was like kind of
a thin experience and they were like
let's do the complete opposite of that
and stuff this thing full of everything
i'm also glad they didn't go for the
like
cut scene-based story mode that a lot of
fighting games do because it's like
that's what was really popular about
mortal kombat yeah and i think mortal
kombat does it really well street
fighter added one in afterwards wasn't
very good and i think i don't think any
other fighting game has really like been
able to live up to like another realms
and what they do so going in a
completely different direction where
it's like screw that we're just gonna
make like this weird open world thing
it's like way more interesting to me
yeah so it remains to be seen
how how it kind of all comes together
but i like the idea of the open world
i still suspect that there we haven't
seen the full extent of that open world
oh sure because it's called world tour
and we've just seen one city
and yeah the world tour mode is from
street fighter alpha or zero three where
it was like they called it world tour in
that and you traveled around the world
and it was a full rpg experience where
you had a character you'd level it up
you'd give them new moves and all that
kind of business and i remember when i
did the interview with them at um summer
games fest i was like so you call this
world tour there was another world tour
mode is it going to be the same and they
all just like nervously looked at each
other like [ __ ]
and i was like okay
or maybe like over time they'll add more
to it yeah that'd be cool i would love
for them to have that kind of like use
that as their games as a platform
element where it's like hey time to go
to brazil and beat up blanca and it
seems like there's more than just oh you
walk around the city and fight people
like they were showing like hey you can
uh uh spinning bird kick to like
platform from this one building to
another in like the dumbest way possible
and i was like yes
i i am like
i bet you there's going to be like
dialogue stuff as well i guarantee
you're going to be like talking to
people and being like
choosing dialogue options and [ __ ] like
that i need just like full yakuza side
story where like some kid is like oh my
copy of
you know i don't know mega man yeah
street fighter 2 got stolen and then go
get it back and you have to just like
beat up a bunch of dudes for it and
there's like weird ah they could have so
much cool fun with that like oh there's
a uh there's a
a reporter who's covered wars around
here looking for oh my god
like meet up with frank west somewhere
and you know sure that would be so like
a good good way to get some uh like side
characters from like final fight or
something yeah i mean like they are
canon as well so
yeah exactly well i think there is a
haggar statue in in one of the trailers
so he's knocking about somewhere yeah
and they show like a poison looking
figure imagine if the stages this is the
most ridiculous idea imagine if they
built it so events resulted in character
reveals like imagine if they had an
event where it was like
we need to bust someone out of prison
and it's like an event that everyone
does together and then you go there and
you bust out cody from prison and then
he's now he's a playable character and
now cody joins the thing
that would be so cool or like we need to
find oh like
we've learned that there's a special
master who can help you improve your
hadouken and you like go to the
mountains and find oro there and you're
like that would be so good
capcom please that's
really good um but yeah so um i have
played street fighter 5 before
yeah during the summer games fest during
summer games fest and 246. oh three five
six sorry four i was thinking about four
the other
four's pretty good um i i have played
street fighter 6 previously and i was
talking about this to you jean-luc the
other day um where i was like you know
when you can
yes feel a game is gonna bang yeah like
yeah that is every time i played that
game and i'm like i feel like this is
this is good even just watching hill
yeah i'm like watching the trailer i'm
like yeah this is this is it this is
going to be it's going to be good yeah
you can just you can just feel it
there's still plenty of room for upset
and it could turn out like it's dog [ __ ]
but like
every time i play i'm like i need more
of this this feels good it's kind of
like and that very like when i when i
played five early stages i was like this
feels slightly off yeah something weird
about this and then it came out it was
like okay there's a lot a lot of weird
stuff happening with this but when i
played this one i'm like all right i'm
in i'm excited i have got an arcade
stick on the way like i'm pretty
prepping for this yeah and pretty much
everyone who's played it has like said
the same thing like they all feel very
good about it so
it's a more confidently delivered
already like street fighter or like they
and also like the beats around it as
well like they they are
in terms of how they're marketing it is
like what they know what they're doing
like it's clear they're like i'm doing
commentator announcements like they did
tgs and they announced two new
commentators one of which is a
uh
a commentator that commentates on sumo
fights which is great which is amazing
he's also the front man he was of the
front man of a
um
uh metal band his name is damon kaka and
and like which is and he's a voice actor
and an actor so like they're doing some
weird stuff with it yeah um i would love
them to do like
uh introduce new commentators in the
future like yeah hit up i don't know
who's kenny omega or something like that
and just be like because kenny omega and
i guess xavier woods loves street
fighter yeah kind of like how uh was it
like dota 2 used to have like the
different announcer packs
fiasco he loves it
um get him in
um
yeah
so that is very very cool
i'm excited to play more yeah i just
mentioned lupe fiasco and it reminded me
that i am going to see lupe fiasco this
month and then it further reminded me
that i might not be able to go see lupe
oh no
i need to double check my dates and if
so i need to hit up team get user and be
like tim i'm sorry no
but i think i should be okay um but yeah
playing that game it feels
i feel more confident in it
um
and yeah it is like even the trailers
that we saw today right like there's a
flare to them that was missing in five
and every time i see it like in um
whenever they show off
uh the character images
small thing everyone's got their own
font
it's not like just
like that everyone's got their own
little font jamies look different from
kyle giles looks like very
proper military style and then like
kimberly's got some jewelry's got like
curved edges on her phone and it's like
oh they they're introducing personality
again um
so i'm i'm excited for for this game
massive i mean i was bound to be excited
as as the street fighter person here um
but yeah i just desperate to pay more
desperate to play more
um anything else
uh ben
uh just pretty much that just
fighting games and mmos
what i say is like we do a weekly like
um fight club where i can teach you guys
how to play street fighter and you can
teach me how to play smash
okay good exchange okay
sign me up all right cool i'm about to
show up and just do whatever i'm i just
want to play and hang out
um i'm gonna talk about what i've been
playing next because it's a small thing
i have been playing a game called save
room has anyone heard of this no
no
jake you should get it on your steam
deck now that you are okay with the
steam deck crew as should you okay ben
do you have a steam deck oh yeah okay
great so this is a
gamer podcast
ah we've made it we've made it this is
this game
so save room is a game which i'm going
to describe to you and um
and you're immediately going to want to
play it
it is a resident evil 4's inventory
management as a puzzle game oh hell yes
okay
okay you've completely sold me it is
literally like
three dollars on steam right now um i
i'm literally buying it i i saw it i
took a chance on it so the steam deck um
it's kind of wonky at times but not in a
way that's unplayable
um it behaves a bit weird now and then
but it's very much doable i played it
for like hour yesterday um and it is
exactly what it seems like so you get
left side of the screen you get the
attache case or whatever or the the the
kind of like
the outline of what's available
square-wise or like shape-wise and on
the right-hand side you get you get a
bunch of items and it's just like figure
out how to put that in there
and like it starts off being like oh
okay i put the gun here and then i pour
the egg here for the egg
and do they just straight up have like
egg and guns egg guns uh grenades the
usual it's just okay it's okay
assets perfect perfect i was i was gonna
say i literally just bought it and i'm
looking at this the steam page for it
now it is like you're like oh it's like
resident evil 4. it is it's
like the rest of the world perfect um
and then and then it starts getting
complicated by being like oh here's
the handgun and the shotgun and you have
to be like okay i'll go put this is the
way this this orientation you can flip
it around and then you realize oh
it'll be like here's all these items
uh one of these guns is like
zero ammo so you're like oh i can oh i
have to load it i have to load it reload
it
yeah like get rid of it again you can
like combine items as well to be like oh
this is a i'll combine these two ammo
types to create this thing i haven't
reached a point where herbs have been
introduced yet but i assume that were
there you can also read item
descriptions so you can inspect the
thing and be like oh shotgun
and like you get the whole like as it
spins around and comes to the front of
the screen and you can like mess with it
and look at the actual character or the
item model and um
it's very chill it's resident evil
um the item game that we all want hit
and that's about it like it's
you cannot ask for much more than that
but i played it yesterday and i was like
this is delightful i immediately hit up
like i think
uh jake baldino and i was because he's a
resident evil fan massive fan i was like
you should play this game it's very good
um
but yeah it's it's very very chill and
cheap so i would recommend that to
pretty much everyone if you like
resident evil i'm hoping that there's
like a little i'm not sure how much game
there is to it because it's three
dollars i mean
sure i i imagine it's like this it's not
a long game but i'm having a lot of fun
with it just doing a few puzzles here
and there and like it's got some good
features where it's like if you feel
like you've gone too far you've screwed
up you just reset the entire thing
and then yeah that's pretty much it
uh
the only thing i'd say is if you're
playing it on steam
uh deck you might want to remap some of
the buttons because it's kind of weird
at times it thinks that you want to left
click right click when you want to
unlock on triggers and stuff like that
so that speeds things up um so that's
the that's the main game that i've been
playing which is great
uh jake you got a couple of things here
yeah uh there was something i was going
to talk about but then i double checked
the embargo and i was like wait
we'll save that for another week
but that's okay because i've been
playing a lot of splatoon 3.
we talked a good amount about it last
week
more the same but i'm cool with that
because it's been a while there's a lot
of nice quality of life changes and
platoon's just it's fun it's got good
music it's very colorful
uh i love how short the matches are it
was the same thing with the the previous
games where you could hop in for a
couple minutes do a match and then hop
out uh buy some buy some cool clothes
um
yeah i i've been digging it i plan on
playing more i think the campaign's also
really good i think i think i'm finding
the levels a lot more interesting than
they were in two now to be fair i don't
remember two super well
but they seem a lot more creative this
time around like there's some really fun
stuff like not having any weapons and
you have to use your little buddy to get
through stages and stuff like that that
that stuff's really cool i love seeing
um
the creative ways they're using those
mechanics for for these levels um
it's also even those levels are really
short it's just nice to pick up do a
couple levels while i'm waiting for
something to export or something and
then set it down and uh
and and come back to it later
um i don't know if we want to talk more
about splatoon 3 because i know you've
been playing it but there's another game
i could talk about before we move on
like are you still playing oh yeah still
playing stopping a good time um
the i'm now that it's live i'm greatly
enjoying uh all of the like art stuff in
the lobbies the the squid kid are in
full effect as
many people probably know that game
launched the day the queen died and let
me tell you who
oh boy that's something that we should
also talk about like to tears of a
kingdom tears of the kingdom that's
right
yeah we'll get into that later but oh my
gosh but yeah the um
the
the memes are excellent i also feel like
they're a lot hornier this time around
and i think it's because
uh kids have grown up i think the kids
yeah exactly it's like i'm watching in
real time from splatoon 1 to splatoon 2
to splatoon 3 i'm like oh these kids are
older now so they're all like
discovering
like you know hentai and gender identity
stuff and they're just letting everyone
know that they love they love women and
demon boys and i'm like you know what
you do you good for you kids yeah good
job
um i think i'm going to jump into that
game soon um i did download it i've just
i don't know if i'm going to stick with
it there was something about the first
splatoon i played the first one the most
that i played but i didn't really feel
the satisfaction of playing it if you
know what i mean um and then two i tried
a bit as well and i was like i like the
vibe of this i like the kind of like
community surrounding it but the playing
part of it wasn't working for me i think
i want to give it one more shot before i
proclaim myself as anti-squad kid
and then go from there but
i think
i think if you do it definitely try the
multiplayer but i think you probably
appreciate the single player a little
bit more
just because
it does feel really creative it does
feel like it feels like a nintendo game
it's just
it's it's very clever very creative uh
it the boss fights are pretty fun too
like i was impressed at how much i
enjoyed
to be fair i've only done like two boss
fights but both of them i thought were
really cool um
i kind of get you with this with the
multiplayer though
as much as i do enjoy it i i can't play
a whole lot because after a while
there's something about showing back up
onto a map that's completely empty and
and i'm just like i just want to shoot
squids and and octolings i don't want to
paint this stage but that's clearly an
important part like that's how you
engage by painting stages no well no
that's how you do uh you get into the
ranked battles because the ranked
battles the painting doesn't matter it's
um basically oh really it's a payload in
the middle that you're trying to fight
over so it's way more about um
um if you you have to get to rank
10
to unlock it but if you imported a
splatoon 2 save um that i believe
already had it unlocked you will
immediately unlock it so you should be
able to try it that mode is way more
just like competitive like you're really
yeah so i i would recommend giving that
a try um
also you should definitely play it with
us because it's a lot more fun to play
with a group because you can just kind
of like [ __ ] and just like you know
[ __ ] around on discord and and
you're not taking it too seriously or
getting mad at your teammates for
not painting properly and getting like
really upset about it
i also saw that the ranked mode doesn't
rank you based on wins or lose it loses
at least not entirely part of it's based
on how well you do in match which i
thought was
pretty cool because
i think we've all been in situations
where you've personally played really
well but your team let you down and then
you get demoted and then
and then it just spirals from there so i
kind of like that approach to ranked
whether or not it works
i don't know i feel like i haven't seen
many games if any do that so maybe
there's a reason why games don't do it
but um i'm definitely curious to test
that out in splatoon
interesting yeah i think i'm gonna jump
in soon let's talk about this other game
though
yeah yeah yeah
what is it jake uh
it's a little game called metal gear
solid five uh so i played this game
quite a bit when it came out
but i haven't played it since despite
the the the desire to restart the game
from the beginning and and re-experience
that game the reason i didn't restart it
was because as cool as i think that
opening is it's not fun to replay in my
opinion
um
but i finally pushed through like i
tried a couple times and i have not been
able to get through that opening but i
finally pushed through um that opening
so now i'm in the world i'm developing
different things i'm listening to some
good music while i fulton people out uh
that game
still just feels so damn good like it is
one of the best feeling games i think
still to this day
uh
i i i can just sit there and explore
that world like mess with enemies uh
and like i love how the the r d stuff
works and how it just kind of becomes a
snowball where you start out you know
using your typical metal gear kit more
or less but eventually you start getting
some
ridiculous ways you can mess with these
enemies and try out different things
like
it's so good it also like it looks so
damn good for being a game that's five
years old seven years old god i wish wow
yeah it came out 2015. um but
the fact that there's no
next gen update
is is a crime and i realize i understand
why there's no next gen update but man i
would the only way
gear solid
next gen update is if somehow it
improves a yugioh game somewhere
yeah probably
uh
but yeah i i'm really enjoying it i'm
excited to spend more time and i think
i've only played like three or four
hours um but uh that's kind of gonna be
my
side game for now when i'm not uh
playing
something i need to for work or if i'm
not playing ziv so that that game has
got the best man of breathing while
running
in yeah in the video gaming history
camera shakes yeah and like the way like
you can hear him running like his his
suit like rubbing up against himself and
him going like
sometimes i turn it on just to hear him
doing that and i'm just like i'm very
into that uh snake asmr and then you
just like pet like d-dog a bit
it's good i like that and then you get
down and the dog gets down on the ground
and then you put binoculars and zoom
into the dog's face and you see his
liking panning like
and he's like you can see his like whole
mouth is like properly animated for his
pants and it's just like oh such a good
game
i think i'm gonna play it again
i mean like i play it like every couple
months and i'm just like oh god one day
again
as as
stupid as this sounds one of my one of
my pet peeves in a lot of games is when
characters are speaking a different
language from the character i'm playing
and my character doesn't know that
language but i still get subtitles so i
know what they're saying i mean i think
there's plenty of games that do this but
i love how in metal gear solid five you
actually have to have someone on you on
mother base who can who can understand
the different languages you come across
in order to understand what they're
saying like it's just those small
details that that i love and i and ben
really wants to say something so i can't
say it because
there's just really cool metal great
things going on in my head and you have
to trust me because i can't talk about i
i i know i i know part of the like i've
finished that game before so i so i know
what's going on but but yeah okay so you
just
okay
can i can i just say am i okay to say
yes yes for seven years everyone has
played it it's so cool that
in metal gear solid three big boss can
understand russian and it is said in the
thing and he can understand it and then
they do it in the thing where he can't
understand it in yes five because it's
just
it's it's all there it's there's all
meaning to it
i'm sorry
this is the clue yeah
that was good that was where i was like
something's up here
not to spend too much time on that not
to give away any details but replaying
that opening section so obviously oh how
did i not see this right away
i remember being like
my voice is the same as uh
interesting yeah what's that about it
reminds me of um do you know how how
like front and center that is like i
love it when it's like it was very
obvious something was wrong because the
same thing happens in persona 5 with
igor remember at the end where it's like
oh yeah
it didn't like connect for me for ages
although to be fair the
they made that work
because the original voice actor for
igor died so you just assumed oh they
got a new voice yeah yeah and then it
was like actually and you're like
no
what so cool
uh carry on what you gonna say ben
oh i was just gonna probably say more
stuff about metal gear that i like a lot
i like uh
i like how in the beginning they have
the cover of the david bowie song
to give it away too
yeah
i also feel really dumb that i was like
really hardcore into looking and
breaking down the trailers while i was
at ign for that
uh and there i remember literally when
one of the trailers came in and i got to
sit down and do the breakdown for it and
there's a moment in in the trailer where
uh like after the helicopter blow up
happens in ground zeroes supposedly
you're in like the hospital and
kazihiro looks over across uh like an
unconscious big boss and is like oh hey
what about him
to whoever you're looking through his
eyes and that's when i knew
yeah yeah yeah
and
i
it was a lesson in maybe cooling down
and maybe not going so hard and getting
excited but
yeah
but the journey
one thing that uh i i find interesting
to think back on is how mad people were
about ground zeroes being twenty dollars
even though it was like
quote-unquote an hour-long experience
but i remember spending like 15 20 hours
playing that game just because
like sure it was a small area with only
a couple of missions but the [ __ ] you
could do it was such a great little
playground man that gave like such an
awesome slice of that game like it just
that conversation in hindsight just
seems so uh
so so disingenuous it's not quite the
right word that i'm trying to go for but
but i think i think you know what i mean
yeah i had the same thing where i was
like i don't know man i played this for
like 20 30 hours and i had a great time
with it so
um
[Music]
did you guys know ben especially you
that someone is remaking or updating
milwaukee solitude i saw your your tweet
about this thing yeah yeah yeah
someone's putting the camera from metal
gear solid 3
into metal gear solid 2 the subsistence
camera so you can move everything like
you get a full free control over the
camera
and they're like updating the control as
well so you don't have to use the analog
stick for the high frequency blade
anymore you can just like tap buttons
and i'm like oh
i'm gonna play that if it does not get c
synthesis yeah
yeah but like even in the trailer like
moving the camera around to see things
like from different the vamp fight where
you can see him like jumping around
looks so weird
oh i'm supposed to see that
um but yeah i i hope that game or that
mod or whatever it is that update makes
it to completion before it's out in like
i think november or something like that
um so i'm 100 gonna play that i might
even do a stream of it because you can
complete that game in like basically one
stream if you do go long enough
so oh yeah i guess so yeah i did i think
i did
two in
two streams but that's because i was
like i'm playing like for like three
hours at a time
but
so maybe i'll do that
um
yeah no guess what five great game still
good
uh jean-luc
what you been up to
i've been playing or played metal
hellsinger
which
should be out now right i think it came
out over the weekend um i think it's on
game pass too
um
that game's great i love that game that
game is is super fun so for those who
don't know it's basically
doom
like the modern kind of doom like doom
doom 2016 doom eternal but
um it is a like metal rhythm game where
uh if you're familiar with like bullets
per second it's kind of like you shoot
to the b and you have to reload to the
beat and do your dodge to the beat
i never played um
bullets per second so i can't like
comment on how they compare but
uh metal hellsinger like
absolutely whips like the it
the combat is like really really good
like for one it's just like the
fundamentals of just shooting and like
the enemy design and the arena fights
are like really really solid like i
think it totally stands like toe to toe
with um doom the only part where it may
be like kind of falters is that it is a
little
um
the environments are a little like same
year one note where it's like oh you
know you go and you shoot a bunch of
enemies go to the next area shoot a
bunch of enemies go to the next area so
you know it maybe like
is a little repetitive but i
don't you never feel that way because
the game is actually very brief you can
beat it in like three hours and each
level
is pretty short within itself you can do
it in like 15 minutes
um
but
what makes it work is just like
the the flow state you get into with the
music is just
so
good like are you you were just
absolutely like when when you're in that
state of being
you are just
i don't know i don't even know how to
describe it it's like you're
you just
are like bobbing your head to the music
and you're just like gonna hit you gonna
hit you and like you just like get into
that like weird like lizard brain state
where uh everything just like clicks
about it and the music
is extremely good um it is
all composed by a duo known as two
feathers so the music has a consistency
to it throughout but then each song
um they got a different vocalist from
uh like a different metal band
to do it
the most famous being um serge tanki and
from system of down who they um
very very wisely safe for the very end
of the game because they knew they were
like you knew that's what you were
looking for uh and it works really well
there's a some i think some from trivium
involved as well so i think sometimes
it's like a variety of different yeah
metal bands all the new and all the
songs are really good like i immediately
started listening to the soundtrack uh
afterwards one with the vocal from the
lady that
yeah that's the second level that one's
got the best chorus yeah like you just
want to listen to that one over and over
it's it's yeah so it's like the music is
so good and then like shooting to the
music feels incredibly good
um and we were talking last week
actually about like how i kind of
struggle with rhythm games and i find
this to actually not be
uh
too challenging on the rhythm side
because
it's very consistent uh where you know
like
i think some other rhythm games they'll
kind of like change up
the you know the the rate or kind of
like we'll switch tempo um this game
doesn't do that because i think it would
make it
kind of impossible to play
so
um it is like a very consistent beat the
entire experience
um and where it differs is that like you
have all these different guns that you
get and you know how
much you can like use the guns on the
beat changes so like the shotgun you can
like fire every two beats where like the
pistols you can fire like one every beat
and so you'll get you know it's like and
um
you can pick two guns to get um
for a level
and so
um
basically once you collect all the guns
then it's just like pick the guns that
you like the most you don't there's no
like uh
it's not like a doom where there's like
a combat chest to it where it's like oh
this gun works better against this enemy
it's really just like what guns do you
find feel the most satisfying to use so
for me it ended up being the shotgun and
um the two pistols and
i just found that to be like like just
firing those two pistols like was
incredibly satisfying because you just
get into this rhythm where it's just
like you know every beat you're just
like
and then you switch to the shotgun when
enemies get close
yeah i i
i really can't highly recommend it
enough it's also like i said it's only
three hours it's very brief it's like a
game you can totally beat in like one
setting um but it's like a
a very very very good one sitting like
you will feel incredibly satisfied when
you beat that game like i was i didn't
feel like oh i didn't get my my money's
worth or you know whatever
um
so yeah
yeah i think i'm going to try that game
out a bit more i played the demo a bunch
and i was very very into that ben are
you are you thinking about playing this
game
i think i am um the other thing that
that caught my eye is i think it was
them that they were saying they're
adding
custom song support too so there's
reasons
and play through those levels with like
i don't know your favorite s club songs
or
that would actually be pretty good the
guilty gear strive soundtrack if it's
something you're listening to
interesting i didn't know they were
going to do that
um i wonder how that would work because
it could totally work because it's not
like the um
the the songs and levels are intricately
tied in a way where like you couldn't
make it work
um i mean they clearly have some sort of
no mapping
kind of yeah the the the rhythm
that's the part where it's like i feel
like you'd have to have a certain
beat
like like if you were to go with too
fast like that would mess you up yeah so
i would be curious i just keep thinking
of audio stuff remember audio i love
audio surf
audio surf and beat hazard were two
games that i played entirely too much of
oh yeah yeah maybe like i mean like
audio stuff is simple if you replace the
shifting with like
shock uh
gunfire
like something along those lines like
i'm sure they're smart enough to design
their way into making it so that any
custom song you shot yeah you can figure
it out on so much audio surface um i had
a zune hd because i was that kid
who had a zoom hey i had a creative zen
so but here's the thing so the zune hd
had a special zoom only version of audio
surf oh and this was there was no other
mobile version of it that existed and it
would just you could play any song you
had on your zoom so i could play
anything i wanted i would just like on
lunch just play a bunch of audio surf
and be like i'm going to play the halo
soundtrack or i'm going to play you know
whatever it was great it was a great
version of that game jake you want to
check this game out
i plan on checking it out it seems it
seems pretty cool did you play it on
steam deck at all sorry i was checking
something else if i missed that but no i
kind of want to try it on because i
didn't actually i i kind of meant to but
i forgot um
i'm curious how well that would work i
mean it is on
i assume it's on xbox as well if it's on
game pass so i imagine the controller
supports probably fine for me i
definitely like do maternal in those
games i just like playing them on mouse
and keyboard
um
so i was curious how that would feel but
i don't see why it wouldn't work
yeah
yeah i'm definitely curious it seems
like a good time and i think the
three-hour
time is is excellent because yeah yeah
there's so many games i have yet to play
this year and the end of the year is
rapidly approaching and yeah knocking
out a three-hour game feels pretty good
especially if it's one that i'm hearing
is good because then it's like oh this
is a
easy one to to
put on a list you know totally yeah
absolutely uh and i also didn't find it
terribly difficult either um if i'm
being honest i i played it on like the
medium difficulty and i
don't think i died once um
because i'm a real gamer um no i just
think it was like i don't know it it
struck like a really good balance where
i like
it was
very satisfying to play wasn't too too
demanding maybe in the way like a doom
eternal kind of like gets in its later
stages like that game gets real freaking
hard um even on like normal difficulty
but i thought i found the game's
difficulty to be really good and yeah
like the length was just
absolutely perfect the only thing i
didn't really care for was like the
story stuff um
it's there's basically just like some
animated cut scenes uh where i think
it's troy baker
is like this like talking skull that
kind of narrates it and he's got this
like southern drawl where he's uh kind
of talking about uh everything that's
going on and the art looks cool um our
reviewer richard wake uh wakeling
compared it to like a do album cover
which i think is pretty accurate
but
i was just kind of like
i could just kind of skip this and which
which you can totally do so if you like
aren't interested in it's just like just
skip it and just get right to the levels
which is really like what you're there
for
nice anything else you've got you talked
about splatoon but you're also watching
something
watching cyberpunk edgerunner yeah would
you like it right i like it a lot so i
watched two episodes as well and i liked
it a lot yeah i like it i like it a
whole whole lot and i'm someone who is
adamantly very mixed about cyberpunk as
a game uh there's a lot of things i like
about that game a lot of things i really
didn't like about that game uh including
some elements of the story
but uh yeah i i
it's not like the greatest story ever so
far i'm only four episodes in so maybe
it goes in a direction um one way or the
other but i find the characters to be uh
very fun to watch um
there's a lot of there's a really great
cast um the leader of the like
cyberpunks that the main character david
joins is voiced by uh kiryu kazuma
himself which is a lot of fun
it's really good it's a lot of him
love to hear it
uh but yeah it's like great characters
fun setup um
it's cool to like see that world from
like a different character's perspective
um and also to like
seeing it animated i mean
trigger went all out it looks gorgeous
like their use of color and some of the
animation work is like top top notch
like you would you would think like oh
anime based on like
a cyberpunk video game like and you
could probably phone that in like
there's a lot of um
animated stuff like that that looks just
kind of whatever like there's a there's
like a dragon age anime coming out
netflix that looks like incredibly mid
every trailer i've seen looks super
super mid which is disappointing because
i love dragon age but everything about
it i'm like uh
so it's like the high water mark is like
a castlevania right where it's like
castleman is super good this to me is
like a castlevania where it's just like
wow they went all out with the animation
and then like the story is pretty good
it's a lot of fun super violent
very horny very horny and very violent
uh
but in a way that totally like fits the
theme of that universe and and what
they're going for um it feels like a fun
fusion of like
cd projekt red style and triggers like
crazy out there style there's a couple
characters that are very like ah yes you
are
a studio trigger character uh in a great
way
yeah i've been feeling that as well like
i think they really leaned into the
aesthetic of cyberpunk pretty hard like
really really really hard actually and
it almost like amps it up where like the
density and like how how overwhelming
the colors in the city is is way higher
in in this anime series than it is in
the games like you at any one moment the
details on screen are like
innumerable um and i love the like
there's a lot of
um kind of like things that you
immediately recognize um from the game
as well as like the table top like you
know the trailer units and
certain um adverts advertisements
billboards that you're like oh that's
just from the game like that's the same
kind of pretty sure they use the game
world as a reference to draw the
background environments because i'm like
i remember that that street city street
and like that specific bar like i
remember doing a quest there and like
interesting like yeah you can tell like
they were using that as a reference um
which is cool and they use the music in
the game too like some of the original
songs that were like on the radio they
use in the
in the show but like in a really good
way like where it like matches the vibe
and it doesn't feel like it's just
putting it in there to put it in there
like it serves a purpose you know
the interesting thing is like the some
of the
like the language and the lingo is kind
of lost in translation because it goes
through like multiple layers where it's
like the phrase tomb is used a lot in in
the game obviously yes but like
in in when you watch it if you're
watching the the sub you're like you see
it there and you can't hear it so it's
like very weird to yeah not hear the
word tomb when it's on screen but then
you're like of course like there's not
going to be a japanese person calling
another person a tomb there there's a
great one where a character
uh was talking about like the police
showing up and i think they just said
like the character just says in japanese
like the you know and and cpd but then
the subtitle calls them pig
i was like oh i guess like in japan like
they don't do that
that's amazing but yeah i i'm two
episodes in and i was like i was like
i'll try the first one and see how it
goes and then and if i if i'm into it
i'll of i'll watch a bit more um on
another day but i watched the first one
and they immediately was like obviously
where this goes i'm going to check out
the second one uh so i carried on
watching um
yeah it's it's rare for me to like i
didn't expect it to be as good as it was
i guess i shouldn't have underestimated
trigger but like
of these days like netflix is pointing
out like just video game garbo left
right yeah so i'm just like
yeah you at fate you could look at face
value i would have felt the same way it
was really the trigger part that made me
feel confident in it because i feel like
they have not put out anything
bad
i can think of right i think their track
record's been pretty good yeah um
yeah i i remember watching the dragons
dogma
anime and oh boy
i was like why is this a thing
i've heard that i've heard that one's
pretty bad it is pretty dire like i was
like oh god i
i don't like dragon's dogma this much
enough to sully my or even like outside
anime like i did not have any interest
in watching that halo show based on just
what i've heard from people talk about
it like i know some people said it
wasn't
it was fine but like it just didn't
it it looked not enough like halo to me
or was like missing that thing that made
me really like want to see that or like
the uncharted movie which came out this
year
uh if you if you forgot oh my gosh
february right holy [ __ ] it's even on
that it's even on netflix now and i was
like oh i could watch that and i was
like
or i could just stare at the floor for
an hour instead of being more
entertaining
yeah but yeah i have yet to watch edge
runners i'm really excited to jump into
it um i've mostly been watching breaking
bad though and that's kind of been you
know
taking up my screen watching time but uh
yeah i think i'm going to put it on
pause to watch edge runners because i i
i don't i don't know a lot about trigger
a part that people like studio trigger
but i had like no i don't know i i had a
curiosity for it but i didn't think i'd
actually enjoy it um but after hearing
so many people uh praise it i'm i'm
definitely interested in watching it
it's just kind of
a matter of when although i should
probably watch it soon because i feel
like every time i log into twitter
people are
on the verge of spoiling things that
happen they're already drawing fan art
of the characters it's only 10 episodes
as well like 20 minutes each so yeah
it's a real breezy pretty quick breezy
watch yeah i do hope that they kick the
merchandising kind of like machine into
gear for the
anime as well because like i would buy
some of those figures or whatever it may
be oh yeah and something like that get a
lucy figure well yeah the lucy figure
looks that would be or uh becca
she's the short one oh you might have
not met her yet oh she's great she's got
she's like this little short um
uh woman who's got the like
red and like cyber eyes but like
everyone like thinks she's a kid so like
they're all like every time they go to a
bar like everyone's like you can't come
in here and then she's just like
tries to shoot everyone and they're like
no we need to we need to go this is just
reminding me i don't know if this is an
actual cyberpunk the game but like a lot
of people in that anime series using a
device to
jerk themselves off
did you see that
yes
it's not in the game but it it's not in
the video game but that is certainly a
thing in the long run yeah it's i think
it's like wide in the video game but
like in this they're just straight up
like
oh that is a weird thing that is like
moving upwards yeah you were just
straight up seeing like atkins but it's
like oh okay
like it started off with in a scenario
where someone is like in vr porn i was
like okay yeah that makes sense but then
like in a few scenes later there's just
a dude sitting on a wall just out in
public with that on and i was like what
are you doing out there and that's the
part where it feels like
you have the the established lore of
like oh that's technically a thing but
like you know cd projekt red's like well
we wouldn't go that far to show it and
trigger's like oh we would
like i was like oh yeah absolutely the
creators of panty and stalking
absolutely
um
uh so uh hedgie in the chat says they
didn't have the budget to add them to
the game so they put dildos instead
she's like yeah that makes sense
um but yeah i recommend that highly it's
yeah i'm excited to check it out more
this week it's really good i like it a
lot all right um i think that's
everything covered so we're gonna move
on
to a little bit of a discussion about
what's been going on from as as written
here e3 fall edition which is this week
um
number one ubisoft has announced
a lot of assassin's creed games
um we can just go around the room and
say like what is the thing that we're
most excited about assassin's creed wise
now if anything
um
well there's something i'm very excited
for with assassin's creed oh yeah what
what's that
the project hex or whatever with clint
hawking oh yes very curious to see what
that ends up
what if i reminded you that clint
hawking was at one point recently
working on a vr game
yeah he well
this this project hex could be the vr
game i mean that'd be cool i think so
but that'd be cool though
i
i don't think
um
yeah i don't know
i don't know i really hope not i heard
like based on that i'm pretty sure that
sounds like i might be i might be
misremembering but i think he was
supposed to be working on a vr thing
maybe maybe
um but but based on the presentation it
sounds like it'll be very different than
assassin's creed games and i just
picture you know
that level design from those old
splinter cell games
updated refined and put into like an
assassin's creed setting maybe like a
hitman flare to it where you can replay
those levels
uh hunt different targets
uh i i i think something like that would
be really cool
that also sounds like it's going to come
out in like 2028 so you know yeah
eventually it's hard to get excited
about anything that far away
but like
gun to my head if someone was like
what's
be excited for an assassin's creed game
i'd pick that one
so i unless it's a vr game then maybe
not
my hope is
that it's first person and this is the
dishonored for assassin's creed
franchise
like or something like that would be
able to yeah that's what i'm hoping it
is like use it
port clinton hawking on that kind of um
immersive sim because the whole hex
thing is like magic voodoo which is like
outsider powers that kind of thing and
like first person perspective would be
very different from what they've done
before go a lot darker make it a little
spooky yeah and it's supposed to rumored
to take place during the german witch
trials as well so you could do some real
cool things with that um
yeah so i would love that ben any
interested in anything that you saw
there
uh i'm also interested in the the spooky
assassin's creed
uh i'm also interested in why they
pronounced it so weird when they were
talking about it hexay
but uh i guess besides that to also talk
about something else i'm excited for the
multiplayer to come back in some way
yeah because i like ship a lot and it's
just the ship but cool and different i
played a lot of that brotherhood
multiplayer i really liked it oh yeah i
thought it was really good
um yeah
why do they call it hexa it might be
like a a um
like this is how it's said in a
different language
i think that's what it is because it's
spelled h-e-x-e
i think but they say exit and i was like
what oh
heck say in german is which
there you go oh there you go there you
go that might be a thing i just did a
quick search and that was what popped up
figured it out solved
um jean-luc what about you honestly i'm
really excited for um mirage yeah the
one that's coming out because uh i
really like the idea of like
the like you know it's kind of the thing
every game is doing now but like going
back to their roots right they're going
back to assassin's creed one um and i
actually like it got me excited and i
actually booted up and played a couple
hours of assassin's creed one oh um
there are
things about that game that
don't hold up very well um but there are
things about that do hold up it's it's a
game that i would say it's not like
um
good
i mean it's good it's like
it's like some aspects about it feel
better
in a world where like assassin's creed
has become so bloated that kind of like
going back to like a simple assassin's
creed is good but then you're also like
yeah but you know the side missions
aren't great and there really isn't much
to do outside of this and the cut scenes
and the uh dialogues actually kind of
rough in a lot of spots like all tires
voice acting is quite bad and and it
just sounds like a white dude yeah it's
an american guy yeah yeah it's like
i think they eventually fix that and
like
revelations yeah they gave him in like
an arabic
little
but it's like you look at that and you
see the potential of like what we've
said this before like what assassin's
creed could have been like the direction
that could have gone so i mean very
excited
at like okay like
you're making an assassin's creed one
that's building off of that like what
are you gonna do with that and so it's
like you know
um a nice lean 15 to 20 hour game
they can kind of you know i think
assassin's creed has come a long way in
terms of the production values of
stories and characters uh so i think
they can potentially do that really well
and and then yeah if it's like really
focused on the assassination stuff like
there's some cool stuff in assassin's
creed one like when you're doing um
uh
where you're like eavesdropping and
you're gathering information before the
assassin uh assassination itself you'll
get stuff where it's like oh hey uh you
learned that um this is a good escape
route or here's a map
and
what's weird about it is that that stuff
then is like kind of doesn't actually
really feel all that relevant when
you're actually doing the assassination
it's like
it's like it's there but
when you're doing the assassination you
just kind of do it and you're not really
actually paying attention that
information you collected so if they
actually like
lean into that stuff and you're
gathering information and you're
building like a strategy
i think that could be really cool so i'm
just like super excited to see what they
what they do with the game yeah i think
mirage is the one that i'm most excited
about because when we talked about this
a few weeks back remember we had that
big old rent about assassin's creed yeah
the thing that i said was like i want
them to go back to one and do it right
and with the learnings of everything
that they've done
since and that seems like what they're
doing
um with a new character at least
um
so well not a new character but you know
an existing character that um
they're bringing back bassim
um but yeah i mean i definitely want to
see more of that game i'm excited to
play that's the one that's coming out
soonest i guess yeah next year um i i'm
intrigued by project red i think it's
called or whatever the japan one yeah my
concern for that one is it's gonna be
the kind of assassin's creed game that
we currently have yeah because they said
they did say it's going to be an open
world one and that to me says oh you're
going to make it more like valhalla yeah
i don't know if i've yeah i would love
to i mean like they they made good
worlds so a very open very big japan
could be really cool to be in sure but
like the problem is they fill those
worlds with like a lot of boring gulfs
so it's like i hope they like figure out
something yeah i
i also think uh unfortunately like i was
really excited about the idea of a
assassin's creed set in japan pretty
much ever since two and i feel like
they've kind of took a little too long
and now we've had go sushima and
sakura
a bunch of other games that like they
announced um what was it like the that
ronin game the rise of the ronin which
actually looks really cool yeah but it's
like oh okay i get it like
feudal japan's real popular right now
and i would have been super into that a
couple years ago but now i'm starting to
feel just like a little bit fatigued so
i'm excited but i'm like
i feel like i'm not as excited as i
would have been a couple years ago yeah
i feel like the way i'm approaching
assassin's creed games these days
especially after origins odyssey and
valhalla is it's like i'm not i don't
care about the story i'm not going to
finish this story if i do finish the
story i'm going to have no idea what
happened probably because
there's just so much bloat and so much
random stuff that like i i don't
particularly care about but i think the
reason why i still am always interested
in these games is just because i like
exploring that world and i really like
the things they do with those worlds i
mean i'm talking like even some of the
mechanical stuff like when they added
the uh
what was it called like historical mode
or teaching mode or something where you
could just go through the world no
combat and just kind of get more
detailed information about that and to
be honest if if assassin's creed red
does end up being this massive bloated
uh assassin's creed game with way too
much to do in a story that's not all
that interesting i'll probably be okay
because i'll just walk around that world
check things out
uh you know i i i think with these new
assassin's creed games it's just
important to be like hey i don't need to
finish this you know i i can play this
until i've had my fill and stop like
yeah i think the biggest mistake is
going into those games and being like i
have to finish this because
some people love it cool
myself can't do that yeah i don't think
i've finished a single one of the like
recent three trilogy of rpg ones i have
not and i i kind of like want to at some
point because i think some of the dlc
stuff that they do is really cool uh but
once again i see that dlc stuff and i'm
like i haven't finished the main game
don't really want to play that if i
haven't
and i'm not going to play the main game
so yeah i'm with you
yeah um
nevertheless
feels like
assassin's creed's in a more exciting
place i agree especially if they like i
don't know if this is their plan but if
i would be totally fine if they did like
a small game big game cadence like hey
here's a mirage and then here's like the
big open world one here's your your red
and then we're gonna do like another
smaller one so like if they kind of go
in that rhythm
you know where it's like you're gonna
give me a bunch of options of different
types of assassin's creed games and i
can just play the one that's most
interesting to me
sounds great yeah right
everyone everyone's satisfied
uh let's move on to the next thing that
was announced uh
goldeneye
oh yes
from the nintendo director yeah i i
sorry i put in just a couple things um
feel free to add anything you guys these
are the things that i wanna i wanna talk
about cool yeah um how do you guys feel
about the fact that the online stuff is
only on the switch version did you hear
about that i love that
i'm very into that uh obviously nintendo
known for their excellent online
infrastructure
that's the thing
so yeah i'm excited to see how that
comes together but i'm i'm also kind of
glad to see golden eyes is out for
people who who are excited about that i
mean like i would love to do a stream
with you guys where we just all sit down
and play like in the studio some like
split screen i think that'd be fun right
yeah yeah exactly it's been a while
since i've played it um
i
last time i played it i was like yeah
this is not fun
that's catalogic but it's not fun well
that's the thing about the the xbox
version is it has like
a better frame rate they're giving it
like dual analog support like all these
things that are like it will make it a
better playing game but then it doesn't
have the online but if you play the
switch version it's basically just an
emulated version of the original so you
get like the true experience but like do
you actually want the true golden eye
experience or it runs at like six frames
a second it's also the true experience
with their not great n64 emulation on
top of
everything else yes
but yeah i i wonder how much of
the xbox version is taken from that
leaked arcade game that came out like um
like a year and a half ago so i remember
i remember hearing from people how it
played
uh
and it sounded like it was a really good
setup um
but yeah i i also like
i've got good memories of goldeneye
and
i feel like i'm i'm far enough out from
where i'm like if i want to play
goldeneye i could always just play
perfect dark a better version of
goldeneye
but also if i wanted to play perfect
dark i could probably just play time
splitters a kind of better version of
both of those
uh
what i'm saying is give me my time
splitters back yeah you're saying
let's play time splitters future perfect
yeah
take me in
um yeah i'm excited to see more of
golden eye just so people can just stop
talking about it now
uh we talked about rise of ronin briefly
does anyone want to dip into more of
that
sounds cool that just seems cool yeah it
seems cool
same goes for three five
six yeah we talked about that
a bit about that
zelda
tears
of the kingdom
uh
that will never not be funny
which is it
is it tears or tears
that's the thing right that's the people
people are doing right i mean
it's probably tears but
around the time when the uk is mourning
the death of a monarch it makes sense
that everyone's like tears is it
thanks and that nintendo was like out of
respect we will not be live streaming
the uk version was not live streaming it
oh really yeah no the the the nintendo
uk account specifically said we will not
livestream the direct out of respect
for for the loss of the queen and so
everyone in the uk just went oh okay
i'll just go to the usa
youtube and watch that version like
not a big deal but like
yeah they did that because
presumably because it was called tears
of the kingdom or even if not like
that's still really funny
uh japanese name according to uh bob
jones says it's the crying tears kind
basically people have looked at the
japanese version of the name i've been
like okay this is meant to refer to that
they could very easily pivot that and
just like dude oh it's tears not tears
but i feel like it's too late for that
now
um
yeah i'm excited to see more of that
game
i
yeah my dirty secret is i never finished
um breath of the wild i didn't either i
was like
this seems i was like this seems fine
like
uh it's very open uh not a lot of
direction and uh these
shrines are boring as [ __ ] goodbye
that's the thing i really want to see is
like
how are they going to improve yeah like
like dungeons and like stuff like that
because it looks like it's it's uh the
same open world yeah um but obviously
like things will be different but
because the same open world is like well
obviously the the mystique of
discovering it for the first time isn't
there so instead you just have to
make what's there
like way more interesting and compelling
so
let's hope so fingers crossed yeah
i mean mechanically i i was super happy
with with breath of the wild i mean
i i'm definitely not you know in the
minority by saying that i think a lot of
people agree with that um but i i do
really hope that this one is more
dungeon focused and and
i did really like the the idea of having
like bite-sized dungeons in um
uh shrines in breath of the wild
but i hope we get some like meteor more
intricate uh
actual dungeons to explore to use some
of those different different tools that
like people have proved time and time
again that you can do a lot of cool
stuff with that and uh
yeah i
i i think there's there's a lot to be um
not expected but there's a lot there's a
lot to hope for when it comes to that
side of the game um other than that
though that trailer
i i didn't get much from it apart from a
date i was like okay cool it's coming
out
still don't know what this game's like
really gonna be about what the what the
premise is supposed to be but i guess
that's okay probably the less i know the
better because
that's a really good tame impala song
but also because uh
uh i just
like it's a zelda game right like i'm
going to play this no matter what i
don't need to know everything that's
going to happen uh
yeah
zelda man like i'm excited it's weird
because whenever they do like the
follow-up to
uh a zelda game in the same kind of like
universe
i always want it to be weird like
majora's mask like they said that shows
like they do ocarina which is like hey
we've got a
zelda game here it's cool and then they
go hey we've got a zelda game which we
made on crack
like and i'm like i want the one that
was made on crack please um like that's
that's and based on what i've seen
doesn't seem like there's much there
like the first trailer was a bit weird
and a bit spooky there's something like
weird the first trailer was probably the
most intriguing to me yeah just they
they haven't like dragged him
yeah
where's drag canon
again
dragon is a great name for him
um
uh but yeah they just didn't follow up
on that it was just like okay now we're
just going to show you some normal zelda
stuff and
the skyward sword energy coming off of
it is is a bit much for me oh
like diving and jumping which i'm like
okay this could either be awesome or it
could be skyward sword um
so yeah i'm more optimistic than
because skyward sword had that but it
felt very like it didn't feel like you
could do much it was like okay now you
dive to this specific area
where you could walk around on the
ground this seems hopefully a little
more open
um
so i'm i'm feeling a bit more optimistic
i
i'm very excited for it but but i think
one thing i do want to point out while
we're here
is that uh
i was i was very skeptical on the uh
the supposed leaks
for for this direct
i said there wouldn't be metroid prime
uh trilogy i was right i said there
probably wouldn't be any zelda games
apart from uh
breath of the wild too so i just want to
say you know like
i [ __ ] knew it and i had no insider
information it was just because i knew
[ __ ] nintendo isn't gonna give the
thing that people want that was all i
went off of and i was right so
[Laughter]
zelda
zelda the the metroid collection has
been like just roommate for so many
every
the last eight directs have been it's
gonna get announced this time whenever
anyone says there might be a metroid
trilogy i'm like no that's [ __ ] i'm
not believing anything you just said
because of that i think it will happen
like
it will
it's it's
i believe it when people say it's ready
to roll like it's out there yeah it's
done it's on
a nintendo shelf somewhere just waiting
to be pushed out um but
yeah so i it will happen eventually but
like i just i just don't as someone who
is a massive metroid fan i just don't
care to like speculate every single week
every every time though says they're
gonna do anything yeah
i i think you're right though i i think
it's sitting there i think it's ready to
go i think they're waiting for the right
time i i imagine it'll probably be in
line with metroid prime 4
uh just to kind of give people a
refresher because right those games came
out so long ago and if this is going to
be metroid prime 4 people are gonna
probably wonder what happened before
um
so i think it'll happen the the big
question mark for me though coming out
of that direct was what happened to
advance wars
um because that was something i was
looking forward to and they
delayed it indefinitely because of the
war which understandable um but i i'm
kind of curious on like the state of
that like are they just gonna be holding
it for
as long as they need to were they
waiting i i i don't know
because we're getting a new call of duty
game in a month which i'd argue is
probably a little more insensitive
uh if you want to take into account
things happening in the world been in
advance wars games in an advanced war
collection but i know nintendo
activision you know it's it's very
different circumstances but from where
i'm sitting it's like
i want to play advanced wars especially
if i can play a new call of duty
gameplay
a a contemporary call of duty game two
not even like
a world war ii one or or a a cold war
one mm-hmm yeah
i mean
all right
final
the the main event
in
hello yakuza games yeah yeah
um yeah so i don't know where we want to
start like let's start with uh because
they announced that during the
playstation one yeah
did not expect that yeah i did not
expect that well actually let's start
with the the big thing it's not called
yakuza anymore yeah that's i still don't
like is it is it it's across the board
yes yakuza is done yeah cause because
they announced eight and it's just
called like a dragon eight they are
abandoning the name yakuza why i think
it's a
i think it's to try and be in parody
with like japan because in japan it's
always been called ryoga gotoku which
translates to like a dragon
and then in america when they were like
we gotta you know that original yaku
support was like very americanized let's
be edgy and throw in like a bunch of
swear words so they were like we'll call
it yakuza right like because we're
trying to like appeal to like the gta
mafia crowd and so i think they're at a
point where they're like
like yakuza as a name doesn't really fit
the series anymore even though like it
is weird because it's still like that's
the name people know about here and i
thought it was cool when for
seven they were like oh we'll call it
yakuza like a dragon because it
to me it like thematically made sense
because like oh you're like calling back
um they were pulling like a resident
evil 7 where they called it resident
evil 7 biohazard um
but then it's like
oh you know it's because ichiban is like
a dragon he's not he's not cure you he's
like you and like there's a lot of
thematic stuff that made a lot of sense
there but i guess they're like using
that now as like an excuse to just fully
transition away from yakuza which is
weird i'm curious if that'll confuse
people at all
yeah i do think
i don't think so i i think they're at a
point where like
the the fan base is so hardcore and
excited for these games i don't think
people are really gonna get confused i
think newcomers might get a little
confused yeah but i think
i i
i i don't think it'll be as much of an
issue as as uh yeah as someone might
think but i'm also not as invested in
that uh franchise as you guys are
although it does annoy me now because
they dropped the seven from seven in
america and then they're back to calling
eight eight and i'm like ah no so that
will confuse people because they'll be
like wait is this a spin-off and you're
like no that one's seven yeah
it's the thing is like it
in terms of from a marketing perspective
it definitely limits like the growth
potential of the franchise by not
calling it yakuza to a degree but then
this many games in who's really like now
is the time for me to jump on
like it's it's very weird like i feel
like
calling it like a dragon
um
as as the main kind of like title is
perhaps a
it feels like a rebranding or like a it
feels it will function and feel like a
new ip in a lot of ways sure um which is
and like
the worst case in the worst case where
there's confusion they look at one
previous game which was you know the
first ichiban game where they're like oh
i just need to play with that one right
it's like yeah okay sure and then once
they get into it they're like
who is this pop star looking guy that is
um obviously that being the next major
thing was like kiryu's back
and he looks like a persona character he
looks like the persona 4 protagonist
uh i also have mixed feelings about the
cure you coming back um i love cure you
i love my boy he's good they were like
they were like he's done
he's out he's done and then all of six
is it it's like this like we're sending
him off in style like that game has this
just like feeling of just like this is
kiru's last game right and then it's
like okay we're gonna have him kind of
like you know he makes a cameo in seven
and it's and it's fun and it's nice but
it very much felt like we're moving on
to go back to him being like a dual
protagonist in eight feels
um
it comes across as like
hey seven didn't sell as well it's the
rest we need we need to bring carry you
back like it kind of has that feeling of
like slight desperation about it
at least like just like looking at it
like i'm just like
oh like already like especially because
also like nagoshi just left and then
they're like
okay we need to bring here you back now
right like i'm just like uh like the
optics look kind of weird yeah when i'm
out isn't it like 2024 or something
uh like
it's got a while yeah yeah yes i think
it's 2024 by then everyone will be dead
because because uh eachine is coming out
next february along with every other
game on the planet
and yeah between us next year yeah
gayden's also like in the fall yeah
okay because yeah i was curious maybe
people will be a little more uh
excited after it's been you know even
longer sure yeah maybe you've been
without them but i mean i'm still
excited obviously like it's yakuza and
it's kill you and i'll play the [ __ ] out
so like it does give them an opportunity
to kind of go back to
the format of zero which is like perhaps
the most well-known and in a lot of ways
beloved should train the franchise like
because they split that game between
majima and and kiryu right so like yeah
now they could do a similar thing with
kiryu and ichiban yeah and i would argue
that one does it the best because like
four and five also had like dual
protagonists but like five has five
protagonists and it's great but it's too
many yeah by the time you get to the
fifth guy the baseball guy you're like i
don't care i don't care about you i'm
sorry i also like i'm interested to see
how the game play
like they have they said
they haven't gotten too specific but
they did say it's still a an rpg full
yeah yeah it's still a jrpg for both and
they both have their individual parties
yes
so they're not shared
but there's because that's the part that
was interesting to me
because
in my head because apparently like seven
did not sell as well as the others it
sold like half as well as six
in my eyes it was probably less to do
with curiou and more to do with the fact
that it switched genres yeah and and
so i kind of assumed
when i saw kyrie i'm like oh they're
going to go back to the action-oriented
stuff but it seems like they're still
sticking with
an rpg system having dual parties is
weird i don't know how i'm going to feel
about that from like a pacing
perspective where you like do half of
your party and then you switch to a
completely different party that you have
to
separately level up like i'm curious how
they're going to manage the gear of yeah
my
my suspicion as to why it sold half as
much as because of how that game
launched right wasn't it like a series
an xbox exclusive for like the first
couple months but it was also on ps4 but
like people
couldn't play it on ps5 wasn't there
like a bunch of oh oh yeah yeah
like dragon ball super launch title for
the series x yes that's a good point you
know
they they push that game pretty hard but
probably that you know
it's not that's not the audience right
like
yeah that's also a good point yeah that
is a like i mean like not to stereotype
but like
jrpgs on the xbox have had a tumultuous
past yeah um especially as exclusives
and like
the yakuza fan base is on playstation
and more so to a degree pc now but i
feel like i'm more likely to if i had to
bet like where someone who isn't a
playstation person is going to play a
yakuza game i'm more likely to bet on pc
than xbox yeah although they're all in
game pass so at least like
and i like that like it's available
everywhere which is cool but you know
now it's like a point but yeah they
weren't at the time right like you could
only do seven and they added like one
and two or something no i think i think
by the time seven came out a good chunk
of them were on game pass no i think
jake might have been right there was a
couple of them that would i think like
zero was there and um and uh kiwami was
but they hadn't had a three four yeah i
didn't they no there was it was then
there was a break i believe and then
they added like three four and five yeah
um so like they were like and they made
a big deal of like the entire yeah
franchise is now available on game pass
which is like
awesome but yeah
um but yeah so that was the
so we got ishin we got ishin which is a
remake of
uh the original
japan only release uh it was a launch
game for the ps4 um it's supposedly one
of the best yakuza games is what
everyone says and it was my main
motivation to learn japanese so time to
go through all my japanese textbooks out
the window because i don't need them
anymore because they're now making it
um
it looks really cool they're also doing
a neat thing where because it takes
place in like the late edo period and
it's all like historical figures
um that the yakuza characters are like
playing almost which is kind of neat
uh they're actually in integrating
uh characters from zero and
seven
into this game as well because those
games weren't out when each originally
came out so
um
you're getting like the the best one is
they're adding all the lieutenants from
zero so kuze the best yakuza character
is back in in and i'm so excited i saw
him in the trailer i was like you don't
belong here yeah yeah they're adding him
they're adding a couple of yeah it looks
great i'm very excited for that and then
the kiryu spin-off which is supposed to
take place between
like
it's like after six and like what
happened during like seven and and
leading up to eight i think it's called
like a dragon gaiden
the man
who erased his name yeah yeah
um but yeah i i love that they're
creating the rgg you the ryuga gotoku
universe like connected universe where
it's all like spiraling out of control
uh absolutely but yeah we've got like
a bunch of exciting yakuza games coming
out and smaller thing but like
potentially exciting is they announced
that they're putting both judgment games
on pc yeah which is exciting because
well mods but the whole thing was there
was that kerfuffle about like hey they
might not make more judgment games
because um the voice actor well yeah the
voice actor for yagami um his like
uh what's the term the like the
people his agency his agency were very
they're very strict about like what you
can and can't be in and i guess they
were like he is not allowed to be on a
game released on the pc
probably because of mods i don't it was
never officially said this was all like
kind of like hearsay right i think they
cited specifically like being able to
like take his clothes off and stuff yeah
because i remember at least a lot of
yakuza people posting pictures like i've
already got shirtless yagami and yakuza
7 because people ported and ripped the
model yeah people already were like
doing that anyway but yeah so
a lot of people were like oh they might
um because sega was like hey pc releases
are like a major part of our like staple
now um so people are thinking hey they
might end up not making more judgment
games
um but the fact that they're releasing
on pc is a potentially good sign that
all is okay and we might get more
get more yoga me and kaito which is good
because i love those boys
and um i i like that rhythm of kind of
like you have the
cure you ichiban stuff and then you have
the like yagami detective stuff so i
hope they get to make another one of
those same
big same
all right
yeah
i was gonna say i wanted more stuff like
the kaito files because
uh cytophiles might be one of my
favorite stories in that whole
still need to play that yeah anytime
absolutely it's very good yeah i need to
play that as well
um okay that covers the major news we're
actually gonna bring this podcast to a
close now
um we're gonna skip the question of the
week but we will return to that next
time fingers crossed uh in the meantime
you can also uh email us after dark
podcast at gamespot.com or join our
discord where you can answer the
question of the week which is always
brought to us by maria aka serious
business in the discord chat
if you want to get into the school just
dm me or lucy and we'll do a quick
background check to make sure you're not
a weirdo and then um let you in in the
meantime uh jean-luc where can people
find you and what you're up to
uh you can find me at twitter at
charlottesip um
oh no man i've just been like doing
stuff doing stuff man it's it's been
like non-stop live streams and and like
preview stuff um
i think a lot of that's still going into
next week so just keep keep an eye on
youtube.com gamespot for cool videos
yeah um jake
i have nothing exciting to share this
week
maybe some stuff the following week but
not this week where can people find you
though
uh jacob deck on twitter and ben
uh you can find me uh unfortunately on
twitter.com at ben jenka
uh i don't have anything specific to
plug other than just watch all the
videos cause
they're all good
all the videos everyone makes them very
good here yeah yeah
uh i'm at tomorrow h you can read my
psvr2 preview on the site right now or
you can check out the video for that
um otherwise we're going to be putting
up some stuff soon about various games
that are exciting and cool and you'll be
able to watch all of that
um yeah so thank you for watching and
we'll see you again on the next one
bye
see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you